so her Clinton is now weighing in on the
Cavanaugh controversy is saying that his
accuser Christine Blasi Ford deserves
the benefit of the doubt an
investigation and due process watch you
had concerns at the time your husband
certainly had concerns at the time that
he never really had due process to
defend himself from allegations like
this have we learned anything over the
years about due process not just for the
accusers but also for the accused well I
think that you have to take each of
these situations sort of on their own
merits and what we have today is a
process that has been rushed that has
been deliberately opaque and yes there
should be due process for everyone
involved
my next guest takes some issue with
those comments Juanita Broderick says
Hillary Clinton had a far different
response when she came forward in the
1990s accusing former President Bill
Clinton of raping her while running for
governor of Arkansas in 1978 here now
exclusively tonight is Juanita Broderick
Juanita good to see you thanks for being
here what goes through your mind when
you hear her talk about due process and
fairness for the accused and the accuser
oh the first thing you think about is
she didn't give it to me she didn't give
it to Kathleen Willey or Paula Jones she
didn't give that to any of us she's
asking for things that she denied the
victims of her husband's and you also
say that not only did she not
acknowledge what you were accusing her
husband of but that she intimidated you
and this is a sound bite a clip from an
interview that you did a while back
explaining that I think it was the day
after you claimed you were raped by her
husband what her exchange was with you
watch this she grabbed a hole in my arm
in my hand and she pulls me into her and
she says with this very angry look on
her face which had been so pleasant
seconds before and in a low voice this
do you understand everything you do and
that frightened me
that moment and I have to go by what I
felt then and the look that she gave me
I feel like she knew and she was it you
yes and that she was telling me to keep
quiet you thought she was warning you to
shut up oh yeah she was so nice when she
first said it to me I was at a
fundraiser that I had taken information
up there I was never going to stay for
that but she caught me before I left and
she comes up very friendly and says you
know Bill and I are just so appreciative
of everything you do and then her voice
changed and that's when she said what
she did it frightened me Martha it
really did you also say that when you
look back at all of that period when you
were making your claims that Dianne
Feinstein was among those who refused to
even read your deposition so what do you
think about oh yeah all of this now oh
it's it's at it's absurd not one
Democrat would look at my deposition
with the Independent Counsel why not
what was the reason that you were given
I'm sorry oh my gosh it was absolutely
they didn't have they did not want to
know about it it's just like Senator Ted
Stevens said when he was in the
committee he said I don't care if he
raped her got up and shot her dead
you're not going to get the votes now
that was in Schippers books a lie
incredible you know you you talk about
long ago your allegation was it's only
about four years different I think than
the allegation against Brett caster
right now and you tweet it out if you
want the FBI to go back that far
basically let's investigate my situation
as well right Oh exactly why not you
know everybody says well it was
litigated and adjudicated my case was
never litigated it was never adjudicated
it never went to court I was never
discredited so let me ask you this when
you hear
parameters that are being set they
really want to do this boat next week
what do you think about this woman this
accuser does she deserve more than she's
getting right now from the Senators in
terms of speaking her mind or is what
they've offered her appropriate in your
mind I feel like it's very appropriate I
feel like she should come Monday or let
them come to her and let her tell her
story if they feel like there's more
investigation that needs to be done do
it but I think she should come and tell
her story you know you think about gun
on your case and the Bill Clinton cases
and obviously you know so much has
changed you know now we're in the me to
movies it's almost like it's completely
opposite because back then no one you
know so many people refuse to believe
you now it feels like you can make an
accusation and everyone is supposed to
believe you what do you think about that
well I think the meaty organization is
for liberal women our liberal men that
have been sexually assaulted I don't
think it includes the Clinton victims at
all I don't think they want us in that
me too may help some people but it
certainly has no advantage for me you
know I think it's a good lesson because
we do need to look at these situations
with an open mind and we have to
understand that lives get destroyed on
both sides of the equation in terms of
you know the guilty party and who the
innocent party is you know what would be
your message for her tonight as she
contemplates whether or not she should
go to that hearing on Monday she needs
to think exactly what happened was it
really Brett Kavanaugh that she can
remember she needs to get her story
straight and she needs to be able to
recount I can't imagine being a 15 year
old girl and not telling anyone about it
so that surprises you that she didn't
share with anyone you shared it with
several people yes yes yes I know I was
35 at the time but it's just a young
girl I can't imagine her not going home
telling her parent
telling someone when any that wanted to
thank you great to see you tonight